Welcome to the Reason Interview.
Well, thank you very much.
Tonight's guest is Annie Duke,
a former professional poker player
who holds a bracelet from the World
Series of Poker that you got in
2004.
She's the author of several books,
including "Thinking in Bets", which
I interviewed her about for Reason
a few years ago, and many of the
insights that I gained both from
reading that book and talking with
you, they still come up
when I'm making bad decisions.
I know why I'm making the wrong
decision, but thinking in bets.
And last year's book "Quit:
The Power of Knowing When to Walk
Away". She holds a Ph.D.
in cognitive psychology from the
University of Pennsylvania,
earning her degree after taking a 30
year break from academia.
We're going to talk about all that,
and more.
Annie, thanks for talking to Reason.
Thank you for having me.
Let's start by discussing Quit.
You write at the start that
while grit is a virtue,
quitting is a vice.
Can you explain that and summarize
the book's message?
Sure. So let me be clear.
I don't think that quitting is a
vice, but I think that people
generally think that, you know, grit
is the sort of heroic
act, and people who
quit lack courage.
And we know this because there's
lots of aphorisms.
You know, winners never quit.
Quitters never win.
First you don't succeed.
Try, try again.
So and so.
My parents, to
inject my biography into
this conversation, these
conversations, which I like to are
buried in Mt.
Olivet Cemetery, which is the same
same cemetery that Vince Lombardi
is buried in.
So I think about him a lot.
And my favorite aphorism
of his is, show me a good loser
and I'll show you a loser.
Yeah.
Which is adjacent
to this topic.
It is. It's quite adjacent to this
topic.
Winning isn't everything. Winning is
the only thing, you know.
Quitters never, etc...
So quitting is a vice.
Right? So the the
point that I'm making in the book is
that grit
and quit are really the same
decision. If we think about
what makes grit good, it's the
ability to stick to things
even if they're hard that
are worthwhile.
And what we forget is the worthwhile
part. So we just think, "Oh,
we should stick to hard things", and
somehow that's a sign of character.
But obviously, that's patently
ridiculous. If you're climbing Mount
Everest in a snowstorm and
a blizzard comes in, you shouldn't
continue to the summit.
That would be silly.
Although people do that all the
time, right?
They do because
we have a bias toward grit.
So what we want to remember is this
worthwhile piece.
Right. So if something is no longer
worthwhile, quitting is actually
not a vice.
It's just as much of a virtue
as sticking to things is.
Because they're the exact same
decision. Any time that you have
started something, you have a
choice. Should I continue it?
That would be grit or should I quit
it? That should be quitting.
Has there ever been a time, and
I don't... you know, modern history.
In the past 500 years where people
were like, "Yeah, you know, quitting
is a virtue".
No, no.
We have a very, very strong bias
toward thinking that grit is good.
And it's a little bit of
a...
It's like a chicken and the egg
issue in the sense
that we can
think like, is it this bias
toward,
you know, is it sort of the cultural
aspect of, you know, like the Vince
Lombardi and so and so forth,
that's making us then be very
biased toward sticking to things?
Or is it that we're naturally biased
towards sticking things?
And then the aphorisms kind of
follow and we don't
know. We can't really untangle that.
But what we do know is that you
can look at a whole host of
cognitive biases which are just
errors that we make in our thinking
that come from shortcuts that
have kind of gone awry.
And there's just a huge
set of biases that all kind of
result in a failure to stop things,
to stick to things too long.
And we'll get into some of those.
At the start of the book, you
invoke Muhammad Ali, who's almost
certainly the greatest boxer of all
time. And certainly, he's famous
for coming back multiple times to
win the crown again and again.
What's the lesson you want people
to take from Muhammad Ali's
grit?
Yeah. So, I mean, I think that
Muhammad Ali is such a good
example of this
dichotomy, right?
This sort of like battle
between grit and quit, because
as many of you know, born Cassius
Clay beat Sonny Liston
in order to gain the title,
converted to become
a muslim, changed his name
to Muhammad Ali.
And then when the Vietnam War
happened and he was supposed to be
drafted, he became a conscientious
objector.